[Music]
i have to talk about your daughter
making her big uh walk this week talk to
me about that dolce gabbana show how
proud of her were you i mean it was so
hard to not say anything for the last
few weeks because you know she got
booked already a while ago and obviously
as a mom you want to just brag about
your kid all over the place when you
know they book a job like this i mean
dream come true you know for her for me
for i mean i always wanted to do these
types of things and i'm so excited for
her that she gets to do this kind of
stuff you know this is real high fashion
it was the couture show in venice i mean
it could have not been more beautiful i
mean there was a rainbow it rained in
the end there was so much drama it was
fantastic
all of it there was a moment where you
went to take her picture and she kind of
looked and smiled and we were so
fascinated by that because most kids
would have been kind of embarrassed or
shy but no like she was there for it we
loved it it was very cute because you
know she didn't know where i was sitting
you know they all arrived in the gondola
you know the beautiful
boats that you know the guys
so they were all standing in there they
got off and then they did the catwalk so
she had no idea where in the audience i
was sitting and i was filming the whole
time and then when she caught my eye she
was like oh my god there's my mom and
then she started smiling it was like
really cute you know it was a little
emotional did you get emotional of
course you get emotional because i mean
i knew she had this because she's
performed on stage many times as a
dancer and it is so hard because you
have to like really learn your routine
and you have to do backflips and splits
and leg up and this that and the other
so she was kind of like yeah i just have
to walk i got this mom you know so i
knew she is confident within and she can
do this but still you always sit there
and you
worry as a mom you know she reminds us
so much of you and you post that picture
of of you at 13. what would you tell
baby heidi in that picture i was always
very working working working working if
i look back maybe i should have had a
little bit more fun when i was young i
don't know i won my modeling contest i
went to paris milan london
and i just worked worked worked all the
time so i kind of maybe missed a lot of
you know my friends
they were all in germany they were
partying all the time they went all over
the place and i was always like
getting up to work you know but i also
loved what i did always but yeah maybe
have a little bit more
party time
but maybe that's good also that i didn't
have that who knows it always comes the
way it comes so i'm not complaining
[Music]
reactions tonight who's your favorite
who should be scared i love jimmy okay
of course
i think he was fantastic you know i
meant what i said
that good he ended the show because who
could follow him nobody okay you know i
thought gina is fantastic the comedian
yes i also love aiden who is the
aerialist i think he is so cute
i mean he's 15 years old he's
self-taught he's so he also might as
well be a
contortionist because i mean do you see
how he does his backbend i mean he's
crazy good
you